foreign
welcome to the simply learn YouTube
channel and welcome to today's training
where we will be talking about YouTube
channels we're going to be talking about
what are YouTube channels how do you set
them up how do you optimize them and how
do you subscribe to them but before we
start let me quickly introduce myself I
am Mark campman I will be your digital
navigator for this video and if you
liked the video please click the like
button or if you want to join our
YouTube Community why don't you hit the
Subscribe button
so what's all this about in YouTube why
is YouTube so popular what makes it so
special and why do you need a YouTube
channel well the numbers they speak for
themselves over two and a half billion
people open YouTube at least once a
month that is one third of the world's
population
YouTube generates around 30 billion
dollars of Revenue in 2021 that is 78
million dollars a day these are
extraordinary amounts and this is
primarily advertising Revenue
now 25 of global mobile usage is for
YouTube it's one of the most popular
mobile apps and YouTube is the main
source of video for 78 of its users look
at the younger generation they don't
watch terrestrial TV they watch TV on
YouTube so on the back of this a whole
community of video creators have emerged
people who go on YouTube to present to
share to discuss to debate to invent to
compare and become famous with posting
their videos we call them YouTubers and
I don't have to mention people like
Gangnam Style Justin Bieber Shawn Mendes
Ariana Grande Dua Lipa and what about
brands that made it big on YouTube the
Dollar Shave Club Blendtec with blend
will it blend and it's the YouTube
channel they use as the social platform
for their videos a YouTube channel
serves as the home page for a user's
account anyone can view YouTube without
having an account however you need to
create a YouTube channel if you plan to
upload videos add comments or make
playlists but more about how to do this
later businesses can also have a YouTube
channel these channels are different
from the personal channels because they
can have more then one owner of manager
so how do businesses benefit from
YouTube
well posting on YouTube will help people
find you on Google remember Google owns
YouTube by consistently utilizing
YouTube for your business you can
increase your chances of showing up in
the search results and improving your
own rankings
YouTube will also expose you to a huge
Global audience
YouTube is available in over 80
languages and it receives more than 30
million visitors a day who watch nearly
5 billion videos
it's the second biggest search engine
coming only after Google itself and the
YouTube app again as I said earlier is
one of the most popular apps in the
store
YouTube gives you qualified traffic
people on YouTube often have a question
they search for and if your video can
answer the question they have you will
get a qualified lead it's much like
Google search but then it's visual
also video content is 12 times more
likelier to be watched than text to read
video can evoke emotion they can make
you think they can make you feel and if
they make you think and feel you're not
likely to forget those videos and that's
much more that can be said for most
other types of online marketing
video also helped to humanize your brand
they bring it to life taking your
messages from flat and static to Dynamic
and engaging
videos help your brand build trust and
loyalty in a unique way
you can also use YouTube ads to reach an
even bigger audience YouTube advertising
runs on through the Google ads platform
and has some very powerful features and
more about these ads on YouTube later
videos can also be repurposed across
many other channels so they can help you
drive additional traffic to your website
you can share them on your social media
channels you can embed them on your own
website or you can include them in your
email marketing
to summarize video marketing is a must
for your business and if you're not on
the video train you will miss the next
stop
publishing regular videos is key and
YouTube offers you a YouTube channel as
your YouTube homepage for all your
videos so here's a bit more background
information about a YouTube ecosystem
it's important to know that there are
three players in the YouTube ecosystem
there's you the viewer there's the
content creator or the people that
upload their videos and there are Brands
Brands who want to reach you to sell
their products
and it's YouTube's challenge to keep
everybody happy in this ecosystem to
keep you happy to show you the best
videos keep content creators Happy by
enabling them to make some money and to
keep Brands Happy by connecting them
with the biggest audience possible
so how do Brands connect with you very
simple through advertising showing your
short video ads before or during the
videos you watch in fact 84 of YouTube
viewers bought from Brands after
watching videos or ads they see on
YouTube
and then how do content creators make
money very simple YouTube enables them
to earn ad revenue from ads that run
before or during their videos every time
an ad shows in front of the or during
the video they get a percentage of the
ad revenue and I'm sure you've seen
those ads while you were watching
YouTube videos
but not every YouTube content creator
qualifies for this you need to have at
least 1 000 subscribers to your channel
and a minimum of 4 000 watch hours on
your Channel
in other words
advertising in YouTube is the oil of the
YouTube ecosystem it keeps everybody
happy
and there are a variety of ads
marketeers can choose from many of them
find pre-roll skippable ads the most
effective you know those ads that you
can skip after a few seconds
just a little side note Here YouTube ads
or mobile are the most effective for the
simple reasons but many people watch
videos on their mobile but also many
peoples have ad blockers on their
desktop so your ads will not be seen on
their desktop
YouTube has recognized the power of
mobile video and mobile ads and has
announced that it will share 45 of AD
revenue on YouTube shorts
now what are YouTube Shorts YouTube
shorts are short vertical videos and
they are YouTube's response to the
phenomenal growth of tick tock and
vertical videos are key these days if
you want to boost engagement consider
using vertical videos
and here's why it has a 90 percent
higher completion rate compared to
Vertical videos
about 80 percent of consumers claim that
the format is more engaging and 65
percent of people find Brands using
vertical videos for their advertising to
be more innovative
so enough of the theory let's look at
the YouTube channels and look at what
you need and how to set up a unit your
YouTube channel
first of all you need a kit to make
videos whether it's your computer your
webcam a camera a smartphone and of
course you need a video editing software
and very important you need an indoor or
outdoor environment to make your videos
and then of course you need to make the
video this will be a topic for another
simply learned video in its own right
but here are a few tips
what make people watch videos
people watch videos when they are
educational
informational
entertaining funny controversial or
shocking lots of examples in these
categories of videos in YouTube now what
type of videos do people like to watch
there's a whole range of different types
of videos but if you want to look at the
most popular ones you talk about
unpacking videos review videos Challenge
videos whole videos parodies covers live
videos how-to videos it's a whole range
of styles of video of topics or video
that you can create whether it's for
Consumer videos or for business videos
now what type of videos can you make
there's a whole range of different types
there's standard format video which is
horizontal there's the vertical video
which I talked about a little earlier
there are stop-motion videos
yeah there are time lapse videos you
could do 360 videos and the big growth
these days is in art is in augmented
reality and virtual reality
yep and then what do you need to think
about when you shoot your video there
are three very important aspects of
making your video think about light
think about sound and think about having
a stable camera position
your light is very important there's no
better light than outdoor light and if
you haven't got our if you don't shoot
outdoor but indoor make sure you have a
good lighting setup
sound can be very deceiving if you're
interviewing somebody on a video outside
you think there is no wind but then when
you hear the video back on your computer
you hear the wind it's it's quite an
interesting phenomenon but it's effect
so best is to have a high quality
microphone that you use when you
interview or when you record your videos
and think about a tripod as well make
sure your camera is in a stable position
so that's the theory behind all this
let's now look at some YouTube channels
and show you how to make a YouTube
channel and here is the simply learn
YouTube channel
a very clear Channel with lots of
content for people to learn about all
topics in
um in technology so here you see the
banner yeah with some good messaging in
there you have your logo here you see
the number of subscribers yep so you see
it's a verified account by YouTube and
here is the Subscribe button yep and
when you are subscribed to a video or to
a channel then you get
um sort of personalized notifications or
you can switch off the notifications but
the beauty about people subscribing to
your channel is that they will receive a
notification when you publish a new
video
then here you have a menu of things that
people can go to there's the home page
for all your videos there is a list of
all your videos you can organize your
videos in playlists you can look at the
comments that you're getting in the
community section you can set up
different channels and you can group
those channels under your account and
here is the about page where you have
about information about the company yep
and this is you can optimize this with
keywords so Google will Index this for
the for the search as well so let's look
at this home page again and the um The
Branding yeah so here you see a feature
video
and there are two elements in this area
that are important here first of all you
saw just when I got on the page before I
subscribed you saw a different video yep
and then when you come back to the page
you can see another video so basically
you have a video that you can put here
for first-time visitors where you can
promote your company or your channel and
then you can have another video set up
for um returning visitors
and then here you have all your videos
and you can organize them in playlists
and in a minute I'm going to show you
how to set this all up and how to create
your own channel
okay so this is simply learn another
example would be one of my favorites on
social media is social media Examiner
here is the social media examiner
YouTube channel
yes so here you see the the featured
video here you see The Branding very
good branding with strong messages on
there an industry report that people can
download you see here you can put a few
links to your social media or your
website or where people can download for
instance the industry report here you
see The Branding the logo yeah again I
can subscribe to it and then here you
have the descriptions of the video and
the different channels the different
um playlists
okay so then here you have to group the
different channels that they have under
their um their their main channel the
social media Examiner
okay so you see coming back and I see
another video here so finally the other
one I want to show you is GoPro GoPro
they are very active on YouTube very
active on on having videos having videos
from their users from their subscribers
having very clear playlists
yes so
um and this could be um different
playlists from users the different
products features and what what have you
what you also see here is access to the
store
yeah where they sell products and if I
click on this I can then go to the GoPro
website where I can buy this this
product
so this is an overview of the YouTube
channel on the desktop but as we all
know most people and particularly the
younger generation they watch YouTube
videos on their mobile device so
whatever you do and in The Branding as
well on setting it up you need to make
sure that it looks well and it looks
good on the mobile as well so let's look
at these channels on the mobile device
yeah so here you see the mobile you see
exactly the same elements of it you see
your banner you see your uh your your
logo number of subscribers and your
feature video and then you have your
other videos
yeah so it's a lot easier to navigate
through one thing that you need to be
careful of is that the width of the
banner is not as white as the width on
the on the desktop yeah so in your
design you need to take that into
consideration otherwise half of this
text will be chopped off
yep so this is simply learn if we're
going to social media Examiner
yep so here is the social media examiner
page yeah their Channel again the the
banner and you have subscribed yep and
then here you see a different color yeah
with simply learn it was brownish here
it was greenish you cannot change this
color that is something that YouTube
will decide based on the overall color
it can pick it will pick up on your um
on your desktop on your uh on your
YouTube channel okay so when again
remember the banner how white you go and
then the other one was the GoPro
yep here is the GoPro Channel
same look and feel here it is grayish
yeah with the banner the logo and then
the um the feature video
right time to have a look at how I
create a YouTube channel and how I
optimize it so I can grow my number of
subscribers to my channel
here you see the overall YouTube
interface and it's very important that
you get into YouTube and that you sign
in with your Google account
and once you have your Google account
set up and you're logged into your
Google account you can create a YouTube
channel
so how do you create a YouTube channel
here you see a your user yeah and here
you see your user icon and for me it's
just why I haven't put any visual there
yet yep and if you haven't done anything
on YouTube yet then this is the screen
that you will see yeah here you see the
videos that you can all access the
subscriptions how you can explore and
you can use YouTube without having
uploaded any video yourself or without
having created a channel
if you want to upload a video on YouTube
you click here on the plus
of course everything I'll show you you
can do on the mobile as well but my
experience if you are in admin mode and
you want to add text you want to add
your about you want to make different
selections then it's much easier to work
on the desktop so for demo purposes I'll
be showing it on the desktop okay so if
I click here on my user icon I get to
the menu of things I can do in my
account my Google account and my YouTube
account here you see create a channel
I can also go to YouTube studio and in
YouTube Studio I can edit all my videos
and optimize them I can check with
another I can switch to another account
I can look at my membership my data I
can look at the device theme I'm using
the language the restricted mode whether
you want a certain video should not to
have presented to you your location
keyboard shortcuts
Etc but what we're going to be looking
at is the create a channel
so I'll just click on create a channel
and here I'm going to add my name and my
name is basically I'm going to call it
Mark
tube yeah so my channel is called Mark
Cube I can upload my picture here I can
also do that at a later stage so let's
create the Channel first and then I'll
show you how to do The Branding so we'll
click on create channel
yep and then you will see that your
channel is ready so what I can do now of
course I can upload my first video I'm
not going to do that yet I'm going to go
straight into customize my channel and
then once my channel has been set up
I'll show you how to upload your first
video so here is customizing your
Channel
and there are three elements to it there
is the layout of your channel there is
The Branding of your channel and there
is the basic info of your Channel
yeah so let's look at the branding first
but before yeah remember we had the
video Spotlight which was your featured
video
so here you can specify which two videos
you want to have in the featured section
whether it is the video for people who
haven't subscribed and then the feature
video for the people who come back and
have subscribed and then here you have
your featured sections
remember you can have the videos you can
have different sections that you can add
here like popular uploads live past life
streams upcoming live stream the
playlists subscriptions feature channels
all in the menu that I showed you
earlier but we'll come back to that in a
little bit
yeah here is your menu on the left
which is also important yes so and we'll
come back to that in a minute as well so
first we're going to do is look at the
branding
yeah and here I can add my logo I can
add my banner image and I can add a
video Watermark which is standard
Watermark that will show in all your
videos so very simple we're going to
upload the images so here you see my
I've created these in advance yeah so
here you see my YouTube logo
yep so very simple icon and I can now
select okay what section will I do I
want and make sure it fits within your
image area and you click done and you
have your icon your picture in setup
here you see the banner image you see at
least 2048 by 1152 pixels and six
megabytes or less if I click upload I
then have my banner image I click open
yeah and here remember what you see on
the desktop and what you see on the
mobile so here it is important that you
look at the text that you have on your
banner and make sure that it is viewable
on all devices I'm happy with this so I
click done
I'm not gonna do the watermark and then
I'm going to click publish
yep so the changes have been published
so if I'm now going to look at my
channel
view the channel on YouTube you now see
I have my banner I have my my banner
here I have my logo but of course
there's still a lot I have to do I have
to look at work on the about I have to
add maybe some other items in the menu
and of course I have to upload a video
so let's go back to the customize the
channel and what I'm going to look now
is to the basic info so first of all I
have my description so in the
description I'm going to tell people
what my channel is all about welcome
to my YouTube channel
a place
to learn everything
there is to know
about digital marketing
yeah and I can make this as big as
possible very I have a thousand
characters available and very important
thing keywords here yeah if you follow
digital marketing courses keywords are
the Cornerstone of your digital
marketing strategy I can add a language
and here I have my channel URL and I can
change this if I want to yeah so it's a
standard web address for your channel it
includes your unique Channel ID yeah but
you can change this as well
yeah so I can say here mark
no actually I cannot change this I will
be able I think to change this let's
have a look
customize a customize URL is a shorter
easy to remember URL that you can share
with your audience and where you have
100 or more subscribers you have at
least 30 days old of your channel you
have uploaded your branding as well yeah
so to have
your number to have your customized URL
you need to have these 100 subscribers
and they have a channel that's at least
30 days old so I can't change this right
now and then here you can add the links
remember the links that you see on your
banner you can add a link
yeah so here I can say the link is Mark
kempman or let's say
simply learn
dot com and I can say https
simply
learn.com yeah and I can add a link I
can say
um Facebook
and I can say https
Facebook
.com forward slash simply learn and I'm
going to add Instagram
and I'm going to say https
instagram.com
forward slash simply learn
okay yep and then here I can say which
links do I want to show on the banner
yeah I can add a whole load of links
here but then I can say just show me the
first three links on the banner here's
the contact info that is marked at
simplylearn.com yep so here is my about
section ready and then here I can click
publish
and now I can go back to my channel
and what you see now my channel is ready
we have the banner we have the home uh
the logo and now here you see
simplylearn.com the website the Facebook
and the Instagram it will automatically
pick up the logos from the Facebook and
the Instagram and the other social
networks that you want to add here
all right so the next thing is that we
need to look here at the the topics that
we want here yeah we have Home Videos
playlists channels and about so I can
add multiple channels if I want but
let's go back to customizing
yeah so we've done the layout we've done
we're going to look at the layout now
we've done The Branding we've done the
basic info so here is the channel
trailer we're going to do in a minute
when we've uploaded our first videos so
let's add a section and that would be
the created playlists
yep and we want to add a section let's
say uh popular uploads okay and then I
can say give me the created playlist I
want to the top
yeah I want the uploaded videos and then
I have the shorts and I have the popular
uploads okay and again I'm going to
click publish I'm going back to my
channel
yep so and now you won't see the order
yet because I haven't put in any any
videos of course but you will see as
soon as we start adding videos then you
will can you can see that we um that you
get the order that we've specified
Okay so
finally before we're going to upload the
video when we go into customizing your
channel you need to be aware here of the
features as well yeah the menu items
that you have so here is your channel
dashboard
so in your channel dashboard you see the
videos that you uploaded and it gives
you basic Channel Analytics
yeah and here you have some news from
YouTube about new features new training
Etc
here you see the content so here you see
a list of the videos that you've
uploaded
their feasibility status is there a
restriction on the video what is the
date that you uploaded and you get some
basic analytics fuse comments and likes
okay here are your playlists that you've
created
here you get your basic YouTube channel
Analytics
yeah you're looking at your comments
that you get so here you can sort of
um review the comments you can set some
moderation guidelines here you can also
add subtitles to your videos now we'll
go into that in more detail when we go
into YouTube and uploading videos and
how to optimize your YouTube videos
but Google will automatically subtitle
your videos and you can edit the um the
Subscribe the subtitles that Google will
will do yeah and very important to
remember if you use the Google
subtitles for your video it will not be
indexed for search for the simple reason
that there may be words that Google
misinterpreted in your video so you
always need to edit the video take the
typos the the words that are
misunderstood by Google change those and
then as soon as you then change the
revised version of the subtitles Google
will then index the um the transcribed
file yeah for search
here is copyright information here is
monetization of your videos it's
important we talked about this earlier
yes so remember where you can have
advertising showing before or during
your videos and that is you will have to
become part of the YouTube Partner
program and once you're a member of the
partner program you'll be eligible to
earn money from your videos but you need
to have a minimum of 1 000 subscribers
and a minimum of 4 000 watch hours on
your videos
you need to set up two-step verification
and you need to agree to the community
guidelines
okay here is customization of your
channel yeah we sort of went through
this earlier and then here is a little
nugget in YouTube that not many people
are aware of and that is the audio
library YouTube holds a huge audio
library of tracks and sound files yeah
and sound effects that you can actually
download and add to your videos you can
search the library so it is a huge
library that you can add for free to add
to all your videos
and then finally there is the settings
of your channel so you can specify the
conversion or the currency for your
channel that you'll be using you can
specify the basic info of your channel
yeah you can have the country of
residence in my case we can set that on
the United Kingdom
yep and it can add keywords which is
digital marketing
yeah and I can say social
media and I can say YouTube
Etc
yep there is upload defaults so for
every video that you upload you can
specify a standard element in the title
standard element in the description the
visibility you can specify and public
private or unlisted so prior unlisted
means it will not show in the Google in
the YouTube search results
there is advanced settings that you can
say you can also in your video specify
chapters
and you can spend those chapters will
then be sort of summarized in the
description of your video and that will
be noted in the timeline of your video
as well so it's really good to structure
your videos
there's permissions yeah and this is
where you can invite other people to
make changes or to edit your channel
there is your community that's where you
can set moderation guidelines and then
there are agreements yeah there's the
subject to the the terms of service
okay so those are your settings so very
important that you understand this menu
right so our channel is ready however we
haven't got any video in our Channel yet
so let's go and add a video so here to
add a video we click Plus
okay and we're going to upload the video
or we can also go live
yeah so that's where we're going to do a
live broadcast or a live stream so
upload a video and here I'm going to
draw drag and drop a video or I can
select a file and here is my about us
short infographic
yep so here is the about us infographic
that is the title of course I can make
it as exciting as possible here I can
tell the short introduction
to our company
I can select a thumbnail of course I
have it hasn't selected the thumbnail
yet because it is still uploading and
optimizing the video yep you can then
say what playlist do you want it to be
part of what audience yeah there is an
automatic
catch filter is it made for kids or is
it not made for kids so it's like a
business type of theme yeah here is paid
promotion is the pay promotion in the
video do you want automatic chapters
allow automatic places you can add text
this is all about optimizing your video
and that is for a different video that
we will be talking about how to optimize
your YouTube videos
okay and then it is going okay so that
is all done we're then clicking next
yeah I can say do I want subtitles do I
want to add an end screen do I want to
add cards remember you see that on
videos where at the end of the video you
see two cards where you can click on uh
to go to another video again I'm not
going to do that for this video and I'm
going to click next
yeah there is some copyright checks on
music and then we click next and here is
the video I can then save and publish I
want it to be public I can schedule the
publication yes so but this is all there
is to it and I'm gonna click publish
so I have now published my video I can
share it straight away on social media
again we're not going to do that I'm
just going to click close And now I see
my video in my content list
yeah I see a thumbnail I see the title I
can see the different details and if I
now go back to my channel
I can see my video in my channel but you
see here I have just put it as an upload
because I haven't added any playlists
yet
yeah so I need to go here to my
customize my channel
and I'm going to click first I'm going
to add the channel trailer and the video
I want to add to this is my about us
infographic and people that subscribed
I'm going to give them the same video
I am now going to add a playlist
so here
are my playlists oh I first need to
publish this
yeah there we go I'm now going to go to
my playlists and I'm going to create a
new playlist and that is sort of info
Graphics or let's say video graphics
all right and I'm gonna create my
playlists
okay so now I'm going back to my uh
content
and I'm now going to say go to edit this
video
yeah let's see if the playlists are here
go to the details thumbnail so here I
now in the video details I'm going to my
playlists and I'm going to select the
video graphics playlist done and I'm
going to click save
so now you see if I go back to my
channel
yeah so back to my channel that my
channel now looks slightly different
I have my presentation my featured
videos
okay and I have my playlists
and I have my uploads
yep so this is how you can build your
channel how you can optimize your
channel add videos to your channel add
playlist to your channel
so I hope that was a um was a simple uh
yet effective overview for you how to
set up your channel so so
that is it on the channel so let's
finish today's video with giving you
some tips on how to promote your YouTube
channel
it is very important that you promote
your channel for the simple reason you
want to get
subscribers
yep remember your YouTube channel is
your so your YouTube social media
Network it is where you can develop your
brand it is where you can get people
excited it is where you can build
relationships with people who watch your
videos so it's very important that you
do everything that's possible to promote
your uh your YouTube channel so how do
you go about promoting it first of all
very important in video marketing is the
title of your video
yeah you see here the about us
infographics you see that is the title
of this video is pretty boring if you
look at most titles of videos on YouTube
yeah let's see let's say if I search on
YouTube for let's say social media you
immediately see the titles that are
powerful how social media rewires your
brain is social media hurting your
mental health
yeah like selfies and self-promotion the
hidden dangers of social media
five crazy ways social media is changing
your brain right away
yeah you're a bit more neutral but still
powerful how to develop a social media
strategy step by step these are the type
of things that people like to uh to
watch because those titles are very
engaging
you know hand in hand with the title is
also the thumbnail that you're using for
your videos
yeah so here you see a good example 365
days of journaling that's the thumbnail
that they they use yeah if you go to
social media examiner you see good
examples of thumbnails
yeah and they are all they have the same
color style they have the same bold text
bold titles they still show people yeah
so these are very powerful
thumbnails for your video and look at
yourself if you're doing a search on
YouTube yeah what videos will you most
likely watch videos where you like the
title and videos where you like the
thumbnail when they spring out when they
scream out of the search results
okay so very important that you um that
you look at that
okay next thing how do you optimize your
channel is by making sure that your
videos are optimized
yeah so if I go to my videos your videos
and then here you have your video and I
go to edit the details
I can edit the title the description
remember keywords I can edit the
thumbnail I can edit tags yeah I can
edit
um language lots of stuff that you can
optimize about your videos another
important
factor is make videos that your audience
wants to see
understand your audience yeah in digital
marketing terms we advise our clients to
make customer personas
and customer personas you specify their
pains their needs and everything that
is important for them when they buy your
your product yes so by understanding
what your audience wants you then can
tailor the content of your videos
to their requirements
the next important aspect of your
YouTube channel is engaging with the
community
it has very important that when people
start adding comments in your videos
that you engage with them
yeah that is one place where you sort of
build your your community you engage
with people but you also engage with
YouTubers in your Market
associated with your Market yeah comment
on other people's videos so start
engaging with other content creators in
building your online YouTube reputation
as it were and start sharing your videos
yeah with them so that is an important
one another important aspect of your
channel is that you need to cross
promote your own videos within your
videos yeah so it's very common if I go
to Simply learn yeah go to their Channel
and I'm sure they have it on one of
their videos if I go to let's say here
data analytics
yes so it's a long course but if I go to
the end of the video
I'm sure you see that here at the end
yeah so you see here at the end the next
video that they promote so you cross
promote your other videos within your
video that you're showing it's a very
powerful aspect of
um the growing your YouTube channel
cross promoting your video
yet another one is very powerful it's
what we call video series
yeah they are
very good in driving traffic to your
channel yeah why because people want to
if they like it they will come back for
the second episode
or if they jump in for instance for the
first time in the fourth episode if they
see the episode if they like the
episodes then they say hey I want to
watch episode one two and three as well
so very important is to create series of
videos a good example is social media
Examiner
yeah when you go to the social media
examiner YouTube page and you go to the
playlists here you see the journey
and the journey is a uh basically a
series of videos
of the history of the company yeah so
you see episode one episode two episode
three yeah they even have multiple
Seasons yeah of this and this was very
successful in their their marketing
promotion yeah so create YouTube series
okay so back to my channel another way
of promoting your channel and promoting
your videos is to make sure that your
videos are outside YouTube as well so if
I click on the video yeah and I click
share instead of just sharing the code
here yeah the the URL I'm actually going
to take the embed code so the embed code
gives you an iframe which will actually
show the video on your website if you
add this iframe code to your web page
yeah and people will watch can watch the
video on your
um your website but it will count as a
few on the on YouTube
yep and then when people click on
Youtube it'll take them to your channel
where they can
um where they can subscribe to your
Channel
yeah we talked about playlists very
important to promote your Channel
yeah the playlists are important and
make sure you add calls to action to
your video at the end of the video get
people to do something to buy something
or to sign up or to register for an
event going live always works in
promoting your Channel
yeah doing live broadcasts live behind
the scenes when you're at an event new
live broadcasts really good way to
promote your channel you can promote the
event you can announce the event it will
lead to buzz before the broadcast during
the broadcast and after the broadcast
yeah we talked about collaboration with
other creators with other brands and
then of course Very powerful you can
actually promote your own ads by
advertising yeah so I can go to Google
ads I can create a video ad and add a
video ad is my short video and then that
video will show before and during
um videos that people watch
yep and that will drive views on your
videos and Views obviously will turn
into subscriptions to your channel as
well
and then last but not least of course is
publishing your videos and your YouTube
content on social media channels as well
yeah Twitter of course is a very obvious
place to promote your videos but use it
on on other social channels as well now
Facebook doesn't necessarily like it
when you link to the YouTube video
because Facebook wants you to upload the
whole video yes so then people will stay
within YouTube within Facebook to watch
the video but there are other social
media channels where you can promote
your videos as well
okay well that concludes the session
on your YouTube channels
I hope you liked this yeah so remember a
YouTube channel is your social media
Network for your videos on Google and on
YouTube
yep and it gives you a fantastic tool to
widen your reach to reach a global
audience and to start building
relationships with your subscribers yep
and help them in the process of
familiarizing themselves with your
products or your services ultimately
leading to them in buying your product
of your service so I hope you enjoyed
this session I really enjoy delivering
it to you please if you liked the video
click the like button or if you want to
subscribe to our Channel click the
Subscribe button
um below and I'll see you at the next
video
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here